it's so good to see you again last time
i saw you was at the bt hip-hop awards
in atlanta i this is before the album
girl i am so happy for you are you just
on cloud nine thank you i am it's it's
all like very surreal
i'm living a dream right now
and you are a finalist tonight you are
performing tonight you've been rapping
since you were eight years old
what is going through your mind is this
emotional at all i know we got eyelashes
on so we can't cry you know like i keep
telling myself don't cry don't cry like
i did dress rehearsal and i was watching
my footage and i was already about to
cry i'm like girl you better not like
you better not this is what you prayed
for you worked hard for enjoy it don't
make it a sad moment now it's gonna be a
big moment for you on stage you're
bringing the energy the big energy
is it going to be a solo performance i
know dj khaled is here he's on the remix
will he join you on stage
i think they gotta watch you see okay
is mariah here
no no okay couldn't get right but you
guys don't want to tease look the lambs
do not play
they do not play so i don't even want to
tease them though that moment when you
two were in the recording studio
together and you heard her hitting those
high notes what went through your mind i
was like
i think i was in shock like
it was so natural for her like she was
literally just getting her makeup done
like
i'm like girl
are you a human like what
but she was so cool so humble like and
normal it hurt yes so normal like i
literally overthink the whole
process i was like what do i say
how do i act like i don't want to do too
much i don't want to do too little like
but she was so cool and she made the
whole process very very fun like you
know this stuff can be like overwhelming
like she made it fun and it's not only
just that moment too because i noticed
how supportive she is on social media as
well she's always tweeting to you and
reposting things that are congratulatory
of you what does that mean to you
everything like mimi is the legend mimi
is a legend and my mom and my aunts are
like super fans growing up like i
remember seeing her posters on a wall
and physical cds and yeah me me as that
girl and i got a song with her so you
know i'm saying it's all up from here
and i mean it really is because you're
going on tour next with lizzo i mean you
and lizzo together girl what is life
right now this is unbelievable what is
life it's it's almost happening too fast
like i can't even keep up
what can fans expect with you and lizzo
on tour together a whole lot of big
energy a whole i i feel like lizzo
matches my bob yes lizzy matches my vibe
and hopefully she can send me like
autumn little snacks that she'll be
eating on tick tock and stuff she need
to prepare me some yeah
you